the Steelers just did something that
they haven't done since 1941 they fired
offensive coordinator Matt Canada which
makes it the first time they've made an
inseason coaching change in over 80
years my grandpa's 80 it's surprising it
took the Steelers so long to make a
change but I guess if it was going to
happen now is really the time the
Steelers are 6 and four which is
obviously better than a team like the
Patriots who are 2-8 or the Giants who
are 3 and8 but the Steelers are bad on
offense they have a negative Point
differential have been outgained in
every game this season are ranked 20 e
in points per game and are ranked 31st
in passing yards per game and if they're
not changing out Steelers QB Kenny
picket who just by the way has fewer
career touchdowns than rookie QB CJ
strad has in his first season then they
have to make some type of offensive
change so Matt Canada got the axe